[Music]
[Music]
before I introduce today's speaker I
wanted to say a word or two about two
great friends of the department neil and
jane Pappalardo five years ago or so the
MIT physics department realized that we
had an opportunity to join a consortium
to build two telescopes on a mountaintop
in Chile and we really wanted to do this
and couldn't see any way to do it
Neil and Jane Pappalardo decided to help
us do that and this December Neil and
Jane and 350 close friends gathered
together on the top of this mountain and
Chile to have a celebration for the
inauguration of the Magellan telescopes
truly magnificent instruments
state-of-the-art telescopes which really
put us in the vanguard of optical
Astronomy then two years ago Neil and
Jane decided to help us create a
distinguished postdoctoral program
following the model of the junior
fellows at Harvard and we began this in
the in the physics department and and
now we have this year for the first time
three Pappalardo fellows and there'll be
another three joining us next September
this is really a wonderful thing because
over time it we hope it will grow into a
program that spans the School of Science
some of the other departments are
already beginning to follow our example
so there are a couple of other science
fellows and and this kind of program is
wonderful because it it
it gives the opportunity for brilliant
young people to do something that they
want to do that they think is
interesting on their own or in
collaboration with other people at MIT
so Neal and Jane have helped us in in in
getting our hands on on absolutely
frontier technology and also getting our
hands on absolutely fantastic people and
and those are the two things you need to
do great science and certainly in
physics you need great technology and
great people and so I'd like to just
take a moment now to ask all of you to
join me in thanking Neil and Jane for
what they've done
now speaking of great people who make
great physics it's time to introduce
this year's distinguished popular
Pappalardo lecturer and you already have
a nice little summary in here which
tells you a little bit about Frank we'll
check Frank was just a kid when he and
David gross discovered asymptotic
freedom this is really a critical a key
aspect of our understanding of the
strong force he's made great
contributions of course to our
understanding of the standard model to
cosmology to condensed matter physics so
he is truly an unusually broad and deep
physicist furthermore he and his wife
Betsy wrote a magnificent book on modern
physics for the layman and he writes
these wonderful articles in physics
today which really are very deep and yet
at the same time understandable
Frank is interested in everything and he
understands everything so it's
appropriate that he speak today about
everything
[Applause]
thank you I like to think of Pythagoras
as the first modern physicist certainly
he made one of the first discoveries of
a physical law in the modern sense that
is a quantitative fact about observable
realities of nature it's a very
beautiful law and in a way it's a law
that to this day is not fully understood
it's the law that the notes that we see
as harmonious are the notes where the
length of a string he was the first
string theorists also if you have
lengths of different lengths of string
of the same composition and under the
same tension then the strings will sound
harmonious to our ears when plucked if
and only if their lengths are in simple
numerical ratios so if the ratio of the
length is 2 to 1 we'll hear them as an
as being an octave if it's 2 to 3 we'll
hear 1/5
4 to 3 or 4 and so and so on well being
a modern physicist he was very impressed
with his work and and generalized it to
the principle that all things are number
that a complete description of the world
should be based on numerical
relationships this is what I think of as
the Pythagorean vision or in modern
language the idea that as John Wheeler
put it you get its from bits from purely
conceptual information theoretic not
notions if you like you get a valid
description of nature
that idea hat was profoundly influential
and inspiring to the followers of
Pythagoras in physics and especially in
astrology and one of one of the people
who made great contributions both to
physics and astrology was Johannes
Kepler who perhaps represented the
apogee of Pythagorean thinking up until
his day we learned in physics textbooks
about Kepler's three laws of planetary
motion the first second and third laws
but less well-known is that there was a
zeroth law that he proposed that was the
first law of planetary motion that he
described and which is entirely
fallacious but which inspired his career
and was very Pythagorean his idea was
that the different distances well first
of all that the planets moved around the
Sun in circular orbits and secondly that
the sizes of those orbits was fixed by
circumscribing and inscribing the
different regular solids so if I
remember correctly there's an
icosahedron around the innermost sphere
and the sphere that carries mercury is
inscribed around that icosahedron then
there's an octahedron then the
dodecahedron then you can see the
tetrahedron and the cube and all these
spheres rotated carrying the planets
around them and as they rotated emitted
musical notes which Kepler even figured
out
well soon after Kepler went from the
zeroth law to the first law and
according to the first law of planetary
motion which he extracted from the data
the observational data of Tycho Brahe he
the planets actually move around the Sun
in ellipses so this beautiful
construction was to his credit
immediately abandoned by him and this
kind of idea that the structure of
matter in the universe was dictated by
purely conceptual constructions like
regular solids when to an eclipse went
into an eclipse that lasted really for
250 years in Newtonian mechanics and
classical mechanics which replaced
Kepler's early speculations the orbits
of the planets are largely arbitrary if
you take this the sizes of the different
orbits of the planets and a star came by
our solar system the orbits would all
change and life would go on in fact now
we've even observed extrasolar planetary
systems and they don't necessarily look
at all like our planet our solar system
in classical mechanics and even in
classical electrodynamics this
Pythagorean Keplerian idea that the
structure of matter is uniquely dictated
by conceptual elements just doesn't hold
technically it's because these the
equations of classical mechanics and
also the equations of electrodynamics
fix no particular scale of size if you
mul take those equations and multiply
all the distance scale by a constant you
get the same equations so you map
solutions in to Salou
there can be nothing that fixes the size
of particular materials and certainly
nothing that would lead to chemistry to
lead to atoms of different or materials
advertised in different places in the
universe being put together the same way
and that's really the way it stood until
the early part of the 20th century when
especially in the work of Niels Bohr the
Pythagorean and Keplerian ideas made a
big comeback Bohr's original atomic
model was in fact based on an analogy to
the solar system it was based on one
over R squared forces electrical not
gravitational but satisfying mechanical
equations but he added the extra element
very reminiscent of Kepler that only
certain sizes of orbits only certain
sizes of orbits actually occurred but
this time it's right or at least a fair
approximation looking for a pointer
okay so you had different possible
orbits and electrons in in the atom
could only orbit in one particular way
then there was some kind of mysterious
non-causal process where they could hop
from one two orbit to another and you're
not supposed to ask where they were in
between by reasoning like this which
Einstein called the highest form of
musicality in the sphere of thought
somehow referring back to the music of
the spheres and the discrete
relationships Bohr got a successful
description of the spectral lines and
their frequency which I've written down
here as an equation the details of the
equations aren't so important for us but
I want to emphasize how closely the idea
of capturing reality in terms of purely
conceptual concepts conceptual notions
that is ultimately numerical notions is
realized in this formula for the
spectral lines almost everything in it
everything in blue here is a number for
a certainly number pi is a number see
the speed of light well that's an
honorary number why is it why do I say
it's an honorary number well in the
theory of special relativity which is a
deep foundational theory of physics we
have a symmetry between space and time
transformations symmetric symmetry
transformations that allow us to mix up
space and time the so called the rents
transformations but space and time are
measured in different units so we have
to have some conversion factor that
converts those physically identical
objects objects related to a symmetry by
a symmetry into the same units and
that's what this that's what this
version factor does so you should think
of it as being like the three that
converts yards into feet
similarly h-bar Planck's constant can be
thought of as an honorary number because
in the deep theory of quantum mechanics
there's a relationship between energy
and frequency the energy of oscillations
is related the energy associated and
oscillation is related to the frequency
at which it occurs in time but energy
and time are measured in different units
we need a conversion factor and that's a
thanks constant okay these ends are
different numbers they describe the
different planet to different orbits
okay and then we have some things that
are not numbers whether honorary or
actual but there aren't very many of
them there's alpha the so called fine
structure constant numerically equal to
about one over 136 which describes the
absolute strength with which protons and
electrons attract one another so this is
just telling you about the strength of
the electrical forces and then we have a
mass factor mass of the electron times
the mass of the proton divided by the
sum of the two this is almost equal to
just the mass of the electron because
the mass of the proton is much bigger
and almost cancels between numerator and
denominator okay so that's hydrogen and
this this physical spectrum of hydrogen
reduced to almost purely conceptual
numerical elements in fact it's it is
reduced in a very good approximation if
we take the mass of the proton to be
very large compared to the electron to
just two non numerical elements that is
the mass of the electron and the
fine-structure constant
that's hydrogen and hydrogen described
in Bohr's provisional theory where
Bohr's theory was just us to Waystation
to modern quantum mechanics
the successor to Bohr's theory of atoms
modern quantum mechanics is based not on
particle not on a picture of electrons
as particles circling in orbits but
rather electrons as waves which
oscillate up and down around the proton
yes up and possibly up and down around
the proton which has captured them in
different states of excitation and this
is a beautiful shareware program by dean
dowager which shows the different energy
levels the difference stationary states
of hydrogen how the how the electron
behaves in the modern analog of these
different orbitals it's Mac only and
it's a beautiful thing that it also
allows you to play microcosmic God you
can grab the atom and spin it around you
can fortunately I what I see on my
screen is much better than what you see
you can spin it around you can make
different transitions so here let's
transit down there see that's that's
this line here and this is the real
thing this is actually be computed in
real time this is what electrons
actually do this is what we're made out
of this is our most accurate description
of atomic nature and it only depends all
this only this is hydrogen if you also
go to more complicated atoms if you go
to molecules all you need is the mass of
the electron and alpha so those are the
two first ingredients in our numerical
recipe for nature
so by 1930 or so modern quantum
mechanics was in place and attention
switched to describing those atomic
nuclei the protons and the more
complicated atomic nuclei in bigger
atoms well first of all I showed you the
wave atoms and I think you'll agree you
get a lot a lot of structure and a lot
of physics out of just these two numbers
but this was approximate we had to
neglect or take the mass of the proton
to infinity and similarly we'd have we'd
have to put in from experiment the
masses of other nuclei if we wanted to
really account for matter in full
accuracy so it's not it's only an
approximate recipe for nature for
ordinary even for ordinary matter and at
the attention of physicists starting in
1930 or so switched or began to focus on
doing justice to those atomic nuclei
inside the first great breakthrough in
understanding that was the discovery by
Chadwick in 1932 of the neutron and the
Swift emergence of the modern picture
that nuclei are basically weakly bound
assemblages of protons and neutrons but
then it emerged and for this the in this
development crucial experiments were
done by Friedman Kendall and Taylor and
an MIT collaboration that protons had
internal structure that they're not
simple objects but are assembled out of
some kind of simpler structure and then
in a complicated history which
fortunately has an outcome that's much
simpler than to describe than the
history we arrived at the modern
understanding of what holds protons and
neutron what protons and neutrons are
made out of what holds them together and
what holds more complicated atomic
nuclei together this theory is called
quantum chromodynamics or QCD in quantum
chromodynamics or QCD we describe the
stuff that makes protons in terms of two
different flavors of quarks the U and
the D quarks each of which comes in
three so-called colors they're actually
red white and blue but the white was not
suitable for the transparency so you
should imagine that this is a these are
white quarks and a bunch of gluons now
these are just symbols and clearly I'm
just joking when I say that they're
colored what this color really means is
not of course the color you would see in
physical physical light of these quarks
color is actually a generalization of
electromagnetic charge it's more to be
thought of as a charge QCD is a
generalization a vast generalization of
quantum electrodynamics of the theory of
electrical and magnetic forces whereas
electrical and magnetic forces are based
on electric charge these are based on
the three three kinds of charges all
different red white and blue
and the gluons are the analog of the
photons of electromagnetism that meet
that allow art that respond to these
charges the big difference between QCD
and QED the big difference that comes
from having three colors instead of one
is that gluons which can change one kind
of colored quark into another by
carrying off say the green excuse me
white color and carrying in a red color
thus changing the green one the white
one to the to the red one themselves
have unbalanced color charge see
something that does that has not zero
charge as it would be if you had just
one electric charge or you change
electric charge into the electric charge
of the same value the photon has zero
charge that it carries off VOC charge is
conserved here if you change one color
into another the gluons have unbalanced
charged it has one unit of green charge
white charge and minus one unit of red
charge so the gluons themselves carry
the color charge which licenses you to
draw the mercedes-benz diagram where
gluons which respond to color that's
what they care about interact with each
other many of yousuf many of you have
probably seen Star Wars and remember the
laser sword fights well laser sword
fights would actually be very tedious
Affairs because if you use photons they
just wave through each other any of you
who've worked in a laser lab probably
haven't noticed lasers clinking against
laser light clinking when they happen to
cross of course it's a movie about a
different galaxy in the future I
conjecture that they're using color
lasers with gluons then something
dramatic would happen I'm not sure
exactly what but there would be quite a
bang
anyway this changes the the equations
makes them much more difficult to solve
and leads to many from any fascinating
phenomena that I won't be able to do
justice to of course in this reef
lecture I won't I'm not even doing
justice to them in my QCD course this
semester but among the rest it can be
thought of as mediating forces similar
to electromagnetic forces that cause
quarks to attract one another similarly
to the way that electrons and protons
attract and bind each other into atoms
systems of quarks can attract and bind
each other into other kinds of particles
well that's a very night that's a very
imaginative picture you may say how do
we know that it's correct and how do we
make it quantitative well the key is
symmetry well the key is analogy and
symmetry as I've told you there are deep
analogies between how gluons interact
with color charges and how photons
interact with electromagnetic charges
and in fact we just steal the equations
from electrodynamics and use basically
the same equations in this context with
the modification that we have this
Mercedes Benz process so we know exactly
what the form of the interactions is and
this postulated to be perfect symmetry
among all the different colors so
there's no arbitrariness in how strong
one how strongly one kind of quark
interacts with another every single
allowed process occurs with a definitely
determined strength and we have
absolutely unambiguous predictions of
the theory if we can just manage to do
the calculations
and after something like ten to the
eighteenth floating-point operations you
can calculate with only fundamental
microscopic input the masses of protons
and neutrons these are those who called
nucleons on this plot and a whole lot of
other particles made out of just the up
and down quarks the gluons that appear
in the strong interaction and there's
also another quark that doesn't occur in
ordinary matter but I it in here to have
a bigger diagram with more things to
compare the strange quark so these black
horizontal lines so we're plotting here
just different kinds of particles and
here their masses the experimentally
observed masses are these horizontal
lines and the calculated masses with and
this is the main the profound point I
want to emphasize no input except purely
conceptual input the nature of the
theory and its symmetries and to mass
parameters for the up and down quarks
and if we want to do strange quarks one
more mass parameter this is all output
so you compute the masses of the
particles here with 10% accuracy in
terms of very very few parameters by the
way there are later calculations that
are beginning to nibble away at that 10%
and there's every reason to think that
the agreement will be precise maybe you
have to do 10 to the 20th floating point
operations in 10 to the instead of 10 to
the 18th to get there
underlying this these calculations is a
vast generalization of those beautiful
pictures of the different states of
atoms being waves oscillating in space
all these different particles consist of
quarks either three quarks or a quark
and an antiquark oscillating making wave
patterns like that but also they're
oscillating in the same way as electrons
but also oscillating in an extra three
dimensional color space the different
colors are getting mixed up it really
taxes the imagination to try to think of
all this but if you liked those pictures
of hydrogen and if you have a lot of
imagination you would love what protons
look like and in a very precise sense
the different kinds of particles are
made up of the different kinds of
particles we observe in nature are made
out of quarks and gluons oscillating in
different ways with the different waves
beating against each other in stable
patterns the different stable patterns
are what makes the different particles
we observe they are in a very precise
sense like the tones that the vacuum can
saw that the vacuum can sound that space
can sound space can produce these
particles and they interact with each
other in certain stable ways that's
exactly how we get tones from a musical
instrument and it's even similar
equations with waves oscillating in
space so we get a lot from very little
in fact the more you look at this the
more impressive it is because the mass
of the gluon is taken to be zero not for
convenience because but because the
symmetry of the theory requires that the
mass of the glue on the rigorously
and you noticed that the mass of the up
in the down quarks in these units is
that making a negligible contribution to
the mass of most of these particles
certainly to the proton almost all the
mass the mass of the proton is about one
in these units 1 GeV the mass of the
things that are in it is contributing
almost nothing to that the mass of the
proton doesn't come from its being made
out of heavy objects it comes from the
fact that these objects are being bound
together by attractive forces they're
trying to pull away because of their
waves and they want quantum mechanically
to just dissipate away but their force
is pulling them back and so there's
energy in the oscillations the pulling
tug between the forces and the quantum
mechanical uncertainty and when you have
energy according to a slight
modification of Einstein's familiar
equation not e equals MC squared but M
equals e divided by E squared you can
turn pure energy into mass and that's in
fact the source of most of the mass in
the universe so really to do a really
good job on ordinary matter you need mu
MD and apparently some analog of the
fine-structure constant that tells you
how strongly the gluons couple how
strong how just how numerically powerful
the force is but actually two of these
masses are almost insignificant
quantitatively and one sign of that is
that I didn't show errors here
experimentally they're not really known
to within better than a factor of two
even though they're the most fundamental
constituents of matter that have mass
but it's even better than that so so far
we've gotten a description of nature of
ordinary matter in terms of five
parameters we had the mass of the
electron the fine structure constant and
then we have two two that don't matter
very much the masses of the up and down
quarks and apparently the fine structure
constant the analog of the fine
structure constant that tells us exactly
how strong the interaction between
quarks and gluons is but now we come to
another crucial beautiful aspect of QCD
which is that the strength of the
interaction depends on the distance at
which you measure it this is due to the
fact that in the quantum mechanical
theory you have virtual particles which
come to be and pass away and what we see
as empty space is actually a dynamical
medium that can screen charges and
affect how charge is a great distance to
see each other they don't see each other
directly but they see each other as
modified by the intervening medium so
the strength of the interaction depends
on the distance it's easier for
technical reasons to measure the
probability of radiation varies as you
change energy but theoretically that's
the same or the inverse rather of how
the force changes with the distance and
here experimentally you see a tremendous
variety of experiments indicating that
as you go to higher energies the
probability of radiating gluons goes
down indicating that the force is
getting weaker at large energies or
equivalently at small distances
or put another way the force grows as
the distance increases which is an
explanation of why quarks can't get very
far away from each other in any case
from our sort of philosophical pointed
perspective of seeing exactly how much
it takes to describe the world the
important phenomenon is that we can redo
we can eliminate one of the numbers and
we've gotten down to five every step
down is a significant step so we've
simplified the description of the world
by twenty percent because we don't have
to specify a fine structure constant for
the strong interaction we don't have to
specify how strong it is it's can be any
strength you want the strength varies
with the distance so I can trade the
strength of the coupling for a measure
of distance so the strength of the
coupling is not an independent parameter
in some sense while in in this sense
it's simply telling you how to measure
the scale of energy or distance because
any value of the coupling is actually
realized at some energy or distance
so we've gotten mast without mass which
tells us that out of the three apparent
non conceptual elements of QCD two of
them are pretty insignificant and then a
third one is absolutely insignificant it
can be defined away so we've gotten a
great deal the whole structure of
protons and neutrons and the masses of
nuclei practically from pure concepts
from nothing at all but to be accurate
now we are numerical recipe contains
four elements the mass of the electron
the fine-structure constant and the
masses of the ups and announce and this
gives us a superbly accurate description
of ordinary matter it tells us why the
thing we call hydrogen exists and looks
like hydrogen and has all its properties
why water is what it is in principle of
course none of this we can compute but
but because well because of experiments
like the ones I alluded to of the
fundamental interactions that we can
compute we have great confidence that
the underlying theory is sound well that
and this
now I want to be I want to put in a plug
for physics not being over there's been
a lot of there it's there is a tendency
to talk loosely about the theory of
everything um and it should be
understood that that's a term of art
that has a very specific meaning in that
sense I think we do have a theory of
everything about ordinary matter we have
a very precise theory with algorithms
only a very very small number of
parameters which I showed you which i
think is going to be our working
description of matter for a very long
time and probably forever does that mean
we have a theory of everything for
ordinary matter no of course not
because what what it really means is
that we have nothing more to tell
chemists or biologists or something that
everything we're ever going to tell them
we've already told them and there's a
tremendous challenge and a tremendous
opportunity to take the fundamentally
simple laws and build up a description
of nature that really does justice to
the complexity and the richness of real
matter now we know what the rules are we
can strided be designers some of us
heard a brilliant talk at lunchtime
today by Professor Joe Annapolis who's
crafting ways based on the fundamental
laws of physics to move light around and
that's a that's an example of exploiting
our knowledge our hard-won knowledge and
an example of how having a calving the
fundamental laws in many ways is not the
end but the beginning of challenging
problems in physics okay that's so much
for ordinary matter we have a quite
economical description of ordinary
matter that I think Pythagoras would
have been very pleased with
now let's get a little more ambitious
and try to do astrophysics as well to do
astrophysics I claim we need just two
more parameters one class of processes
that's very important in astrophysics
are the processes that cause stars to
burn and those are the weak processes at
a fundamental level they're described in
terms of the possibility of down quarks
turning into up quarks plus electrons
plus anti neutrinos or actually this is
the this is the process of beta decay
there's a close it's closely related you
just bend around the lines and you get
the processes that are responsible for
stellar burning okay so this although it
just looks like a silly picture to a
physicist who knows about relativistic
quantum field theory which has very very
rigid rules is actually associated with
a complete and unambiguous description
of the weak interactions and all we need
to add to our numerical recipe is one
parameter which tells us about how big
this process is how rapidly it occurs
overall one over all no normal new
constant and that's called the Fermi
constant G sub F
and then for Astrophysics the other
thing that's very important that we
haven't mentioned so far is gravity
gravity you might think is since it's so
obvious it must be the very feeble must
be a very powerful force and we've been
silly to be neglecting it so far however
at a fundamental level gravity is
actually extravagantly feeble it only
winds on in astrophysics by default if
you for instance compare the strength of
the attraction between a proton and
electron due to their electrical
interaction which goes like one over R
squared - their gravitational attraction
which also goes like one over R squared
you'll find that the electric attraction
is about 40 orders of magnitude larger
one followed by 40 zeroes an
extraordinarily large number physicists
like to put it in terms of something
called the hierarchy problem to make it
quantitative if we want a quantitative
measure of how strong gravity is
fundamentally well we have to ask
compared to what and since most of the
mass of matter is made in protons we
have to construct a dimensionless
quantity a pure number out of the
fundament of the Honorary numbers
Newton's constant and the mass of the
proton and that can be done in one and
only one way and it gives a number ten
to the minus thirty eight that tells us
that gravity in any real set in any
natural sense in a fundamental sense is
an extravagantly feeble force it can
dominate in astrophysics because the
other more powerful forces
being more powerful rearrange matter in
such a way as to cancel each other out
to reach equilibrium and neutrality but
gravity keeps adding up and eventually
on large enough scale wins out
now previously I said that Planck's
constant H bar and the speed of light C
should be through thought of as honorary
numbers because in profound theories of
nature they occur as conversion factors
now I'd like to argue that Newton's
constant that governs the strength of
gravity is also an honorary number
that's because it's associated with the
profound theory of general relativity as
a conversion factor in general
relativity there's a relationship
between the curvature of space-time and
the the energy density of matter but
those have different units the curvature
of space-time has different units from
the energy of dense intensity of matter
need a conversion factor to relate them
and that conversion factor turns out to
be Newton's constant so if we think that
GN is an honorary number the question
posed by this extravagantly weakness of
gravity gets viewed in a totally
different way G Newton is not small it
just is what it is it's a conversion
it's a primary number it's a conversion
factor H the H bar and C all of them are
honorary numbers they just are what they
are there's no way of them being either
large or small so the real question is
why is the proton mass so light why is
the proton and why is the proton so
light well why is the proton so light
well earlier in the lecture I told you
how the proton gets its mass so we can
address the question why is the proton
so light
and the answer is that you must walk
before you run well that I think
probably sounds very cryptic to most of
you so let me explain it better as I
discussed the strength of the
interaction with which quarks and
attract each other depends on the
distance and the dependence is something
that's we can predict theoretically and
has also been measured in a variety of
experiments up to energies of 100 GeV we
can extrapolate all the way to the
fundamental energy which if we believe
that Newton's constant is an honorary
number we can identify as 10 to the 19th
proton masses or 10 to the 19th GeV way
out here somewhere and the thing that
governs the mass of the proton is that
at these distances out here at the
fundamental distances the forces are too
weak quarks to keep them locked to each
other it has to build up but the
coupling due to quantum mechanical
fluctuations that we talked about the
screening effect only changes very very
slowly at first until a cloud of charge
builds up and gets bigger and bigger so
it's walking it's actually sort of
limping along like a wounded snail for a
long time until it slowly builds up and
then finally at of course not
coincidentally a length corresponding to
the mass of the proton it becomes strong
enough to bind the quarks together
that's why protons are so light in
natural units it comes about because the
coupling was a little bit small at the
fundamental scale and given that it's a
little bit small it takes a long long
time
for the small quantum mechanical effects
to build up and make it big and
eventually bind protons fine quarks into
protons now as I said well so now we've
we've introduced we have a description
of matter which is a very accurate
description including both ordinary
matter and astrophysics based on six
quantities the fine structure constant
the mass of the electron the masses of
the up and down quarks the Newton
constant and and the Fermi constant
there are the things that appear in red
on your program but I've just been
trying to actually improve I said each
time you make an improvement on that
you're making a major contribution to
physics so I've just been trying to
implement the idea if you like or
discuss the idea that Planck's constant
two should be regarded as an honorary
number and we scored a significant
success for that point of view by
explaining how the proton could be so
absurdly light measured in those natural
units we're putting it another way why
gravity is so feeble
now if that explanation if we're going
to succeed in actually promoting the
Newton constant to an honorary number
and explain and reduce our numerical
recipe it has to work not only for QCD
but also for the other interactions in
the world or let me put it another way
we would like to see that same that that
same scale that Newton constant emerge
in some other way in physics as that's
independent of the theory of gravity
well remarkably enough there is another
way in which the Newton constant emerges
from quite different considerations in
our fundamental theories of physics as I
told you the couplings change with
distance very very slowly here to make
the plot look simple and be able to fit
it on one little sheet we switched to a
logarithmic scale and plotted inverse
couplings instead of couplings and I've
have here not the fine-structure
constant for QCD the fine-structure
constant for electrodynamics and an
analogous thing that occurs in the weak
interactions that I haven't described
but is something that is important in
particle physics and you can ask if all
these different interactions that we see
at low energies might be different
manifestations of a unified theory that
a that is simple in its operations at
short distances but gets obscured from
us by the same quantum mechanical
fluctuations and screening effects that
make the couplings change the distance
so operationally we have to take these
guys from experiment that's where we
measure them and then theoretically
calculate what the effect of the
screening is to see if they could have
derived from unified
and remarkably enough they do the
measured values are consistent with
their emerging from a unified theory
where they all become equal and all
become different facets of one
interaction and that occurs at an energy
that's very similar to the energy we
extract the Planck scale we extract from
Newton's constant there's 10 to the 19th
GeV so if we ask could there be a
unified theory of matter we get the
resounding answer that yes not only
could there be but there's a strong
indication that the different very
different-looking interactions we see at
low energies are all facets of one
unified theory at high energies and if
we do further experiments further
discoveries including the existence of
neutrino mass which is in its details
supports the idea of such unified
theories the unified theories also
predict that proton stirs decay that one
hasn't been observed yet so we get two
exclamation points in a question mark to
our question is there a unified theory
of matter that can congeals at something
close to this Planck scale
but then the final step must be to bring
back in gravity well gravity is also
sensitive to the energy at which you
measure and not just because of subtle
quantum mechanical effects but because
gravity just cares about energy the
gravitational force is proportional to
mass or a chord energy according to a
equals MC squared so the higher the
energy the stronger gravity appears
relative to the other interactions and
so for the inverse coupling of gravity
on this logarithmic scale happens to
look like that and you can see that
gravity also seems to be joining the
other interactions we can't do this
calculation very accurately but to the
accuracy that it deserves it's
consistent with the idea that all these
interactions unite together so the basic
idea that Newton's constant can be
regarded as an honorary number and
should be the fundamental mass that
appears in the fundamental unified
theory holds up very well from two very
different perspectives it's the scale at
which we get an at which the in there's
independent indication of a fundamental
theory of emerging of the
non-gravitational forces and it's also
the scale at which gravity meets those
and potentially a fully unified theory
that includes not just a theory of
matter but also the theory of space and
time which is what gravity is in general
in Einstein's general relativity theory
so to the question do these
considerations of the numerical recipe
for nature point us toward a unified
theory of space-time matter
this one does but really that's the only
quantitative indication so far along
those lines and there are big puzzles in
trying to construct a unified theory
with gravity and the other interactions
there's the puzzle of why empty space
doesn't weigh anything and there's just
the puzzle that we don't have any very
concrete theory along these lines there
are the germs of ideas coming from
string theory that perhaps will congeal
into a well-defined theory but at
present it's kind of a vague assemblage
of ideas so let me summarize to
construct ordinary matter to construct a
description of ordinary matter that's
extremely precise and very well verified
we were able to get by with a couple of
honorary numbers h-bar and C and for non
numerical quantities exactly for the
mass of the electron the fine-structure
constant and the masses of the ups and
down quarks and among those the masses
of the up quarks and down quarks didn't
matter very much quantitatively if we
want to do astrophysics as well we
needed to add just two more numbers the
the Fermi constant describing the weak
interactions and the Newton's constant
describing the strength of gravity and
then finally I gave you a series of
arguments sort of at the frontiers of
physics
indicating that the idea that we can
treat Newton's constant also as an
honorary number is becoming very very
plausible we get at that number from
considering unified theories of the
other interactions and how they emerge
we get a convincing explanation of why
gravity is so feeble
based on interpreting it as actually the
lightness of protons which in turn was
interpreted as the coupling having to
run to walk before it runs and then
finally from the just straight
calculation of whether gravity unifies
with the other interactions so the
Pythagorean vision that the world can be
described in terms of pure numbers is
very very close to being realized in a
very concrete and beautiful way that I
hope I've given you some inkling of
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
yes okay I tried to associate myself
very carefully from the philosophy if
you want to call it that that in physics
you're done once you write down the
equations it's an important part of
physics to write down the equations but
to really be able to solve them in
meaningful circumstances to be able to
do them justice to relate them to the
world is a tremendous art and every bit
is important and challenging as finding
the equations yes
well that does actually come out of so
the question was the if you actually
look in detail at some of the properties
of our quarks and electrons they're a
little funny
for instance the the charge of the
electric charge of the up quark is tooth
it has to be two thirds the electric
charge of or minus two thirds the
electric charge tooth the electric
charge of the electron and the electric
charge of the down quark is one third
the electric charge of the electron
where did these funny numbers like
two-thirds and one-third come from well
first of all since they're numbers
they're not anti Pythagorean but
secondly and more seriously they are
among the most I I haven't been able to
do it justice and I won't be able to do
it justice and in this brief lecture but
they are one of they merge in a very
compelling way from these unified
theories see how can I say this in a
simple way you see
yeah the physical photon as we observe
it is some mixture of the gluons in the
fundamental theory and so are the gluons
of the strong interaction they're
mixtures and which particular mixtures
emerge as the photon and emerge as the
colored gluons is determined by the
details of how this symmetry breaks of
how the big symmetry of the original
underlying theory breaks so to address
questions like the relative charges of
different objects we need to be specific
about what this theory was and about how
it how the original highly symmetrical
theory broke down into the less
symmetrical theories we actually see at
low energies I can be a little bit more
specific about this and give you some
idea of how it works but to really do it
would require some equations I emphasize
that the theory of electrodynamics was
mathematic on SEPs to the theory of QCD
they were both based on different kinds
of charges also called colors and their
transformations and interactions with
with photons or gluons the form of this
unified theory I'd actually say the
theory of the weak interaction is based
on a similar idea involving two other
colors so all these theories are
different kinds of theories of different
kinds of charges interacting with
different kinds of gluons the unified
theory is simply including all possible
transformations among all the colors
strong weak and electromagnetic and
seeing if they can be incorporated on
equal footing and that the calculation
here shows that that idea succeeds then
you have to discuss well why isn't the
world as why in the real world don't we
see all these interactions on an equal
footing what happened and that's the
subject that's the phenomenon is called
spontaneous symmetry breaking and
it'll sound poetic but it's it's
literally the case that what's involved
here is the concept that the whole world
is a multi-layered multicolored
superconductor ordinary superconductors
have the are governed by the concept
that you have so-called Cooper pairs of
electrons pairing up and filling a metal
and giving a photon of mass and having
affecting the properties of photons
effectively giving photons a mass inside
superconductors in these theories what
we need is not pairs of electrons as in
superconductors but pairs of similar
things carrying other kinds of colored
charges filling and what we think of as
empty space but it's of course it's not
empty it's a multi-layered
multi-coloured superconductor because it
has these pairs it's filled
chock-a-block with pairs of particles
with different colors and it's the
presence of that medium that
distinguishes the different colors
between strong electromagnetic and weak
say this these pairs have more are more
aligned in the direction of the weak
interaction than the strong interaction
and that distinguishes the two
directions and and breaks the symmetry
well I'm trying to trying to say
something that's easier done than said
as thick but be well maybe I'm giving
you some sense that it's the details of
how the symmetry is broken that
determines the charges at the end of the
day and varies if you take the sort of
the simplest possible possibilities for
how the symmetry is broken that's what
gives you the structures we observe at
low energies including things like the
charge two-thirds and one thirds on the
quark that otherwise seemed so funny
yeah
every slide yes when you were showing
the pairs their apparent reds paired
blues but no green all right
they're real for not okay so you might
think if we have gluons to change any
possible color into any other color
including the same one that there would
be nine possibilities three times three
uh and there are of course but one of
those colored gluons well the joke I
might like to make is that these are
gauge bosons but one of them is a gauge
bogan it's bogus there's one that's
different from all the rest and it's
composed of an equal combination of the
red anti red blue anti blue and white
anti white or green anti green in
quantum mechanics you're allowed to take
linear combinations of these different
possibilities and the gluon which treats
all those colors symmetrically doesn't
has different ugly state has different
properties than any of these other guys
which don't treat the different colors
symmetrically if you know a little group
Theory if you take a product of a
triplet and an anti triplet
representation of color which is what we
have here they form an octet eight
gluons which is perfectly symmetrical
and a singlet which has different
properties so in the theory of the
strong interaction that singlet doesn't
participate it's just it's different
from the rest it and so to enforce the
proper symmetry of the strong
interaction and agree with nature it's
consistent and necessary to throw it out
okay so actually it's a slight lie well
it's a big lie to to just leave out the
green anti green what I should have
written here was red red red anti red -
blue
anteye blue and something like blue in
Thai blue - green anti green then it
would have been mathematically correct
but probably even more confusing yes why
why do I see nine decimal places the
same fine structure constant in hydrogen
in singly ionized helium you don't I
mean when you do accurate calculations
of the force between say electrons
between an electron and a positron or
whatever I guess one of you you find
that the force does change logarithmic
this is the Yuling effect or vacuum
polarization which appears in atomic
physics so yeah well these calculations
are done basically neglecting the masses
of particles relative to the energy and
that's valid for all the particles we
know about sort of from here on out but
if it would be totally invalid yeah they
flattened that they'd be well they
flattened out in the these two cases in
this case
they it well son not exactly known it
becomes a strong coupling problem and
it's not really well-defined but that
anyway yeah you can't just extrapolate
these curves that's quite right yes
converging to these curves to sort of
try to dub a couple look your constancy
for all three numbers just okay but
don't you get a few so what is Ken I
mean for instance alpha yes you turned
that into our owner a number by saying
well really lambda few CD just sets the
length scale but then the Planck length
you're trying to tell me is somewhat of
a sleight of hand here if I make the
Planck length the scale of length and
run through my explanation of why
gravity is feeble or why protons are so
light that explanation required on note
knowing what the value of alpha s was at
the Planck length so if I do it that way
I reintroduce a numerical parameter okay
so you're quite right
[Laughter]
well for those of you who didn't catch
this let me just remark that 81 divided
by 64 is very close to
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]